good morning I'm John class and director
of competition for Great Race and we're
I'm going to do the first hour of rally
school we're about ten minutes late but
if we run over by about ten minutes
you'll still be able to all make the
start the official start time of today's
run is 11:30 I'll go for about an hour
we'll take a 10 or 15-minute break bill
croaker will do the second half of rally
school and when the first half is over I
have to get out of here really quick
because we're gonna we have to go out
and lead the round get all the
checkpoints set up and make sure that
Rob hasn't flooded out what's this deal
all about this is the great race and
this was alluded to by Jim anello a
little earlier but what does that mean
does that mean that the car that runs
the fastest the first car that gets to
Springfield Missouri tomorrow the first
car that gets to Santa Monica in a week
will be the winner and the answer to
that is of course no we can't do a
fastest car wins type event on public
roads so the nature of the great race is
a controlled speed endurance road rally
we give you or we'll give you or in the
case of today's run have given you
precise driving instructions telling you
what roads to take what speeds to try to
attain when to leave various places and
if you do the competition as we
described if we leave the point you're
supposed to leave at exactly the right
time if you follow the route we give you
if you go exactly the speeds that we
give you you will have dumb competition
exactly correctly you will win $50,000
and you'll get a trip to Japan how do we
know whether or not you are doing the
competition correctly how do we know
whether or not you are following the
route we give you how do we know whether
or not you work at a painting the speeds
that we have assigned the answer to that
is that we will check on your progress
several times each day and the way
we will do that is at various
checkpoints now there are two types of
checkpoints that you will encounter each
day the first one I'm going to talk
about this will almost certainly not be
the first one you will encounter but the
first one I'm going to talk about is the
observation checkpoint the observation
checkpoint is identified by a red sign
it says stop first time we're going to
talk about is the red sign the stop sign
it will not be at that altitude it will
be on the ground like this when you see
they're holding when you see the red
sign you will do it as sense red means
stop you need to stop and talk to the
worker there are several purposes for
which we will have the red signs one of
which may be to have an inspection
checkpoint make sure you don't have any
illegal equipment in the car second of
which may be to collect time allowances
the third of which may be to and will be
this is the most likely place you will
get you will encounter a red sign each
day is at the finish line each day at
the finish line each day we will check
you in if all goes well we may have your
checkpoint times or your scores for the
day and we will mark your card give you
will endorse of course instructions to
verify that you have been here red sign
red means stop talk to the workers there
may also give you emergency instructions
the road is flooded today we will have
to flag you down and flag you down and
give you emergency instructions red sign
red means stop the more common sign you
will encounter is the green sign green
sign is a timing checkpoint and a green
sign we will time you and we will give
you a score you won't know what it is we
will give you a score on the
portion of the event that just ended
we're going to talk about some
terminology now the term stage refers to
a day of competition today's stage is
the trophy riding tomorrow is stage one
the next day of stage two each day's
instructions will say on the front cover
stage stage number stage number one and
the footer of each page will state's a
stage number the term stage refers to
the day of competition the term leg is a
portion of a day's competition a portion
of a stage that ends at a check point
and the third term I'm going to talk
about is checkpoint legs and checkpoints
are sort of referred to interchangeably
they're not quite the same a leg is a
portion of the route that ends at a
checkpoint
the checkpoint is where we time you at
the end of a leg when you start the run
today you will be on leg one you will be
on leg one from there until you get to
the first green sign checkpoint one
immediately you will begin leg two you
will be on leg two until you get to the
second green sign checkpoint two and so
on at the red sign I told you what you
needed to do red means stop stop talk to
the workers green sign what do you do
you like this answer the minimum that
you need to do at a green sign green
means go the minimum that you need to do
is nothing there are things I'd like you
to do but we will do all the work we
will we will time you at the checkpoint
we will get a time based on that we'll
give you a score we'll send that to a
computer central scoring central and do
all the calculation what would I like
you to do at a checkpoint what I would
like you to do is write down where
perhaps right there in your course
instructions the instruction you're
working on right down that checkpoint
one first when you get to and the time
you arrive there hours minutes and
seconds nine o'clock 22 minutes 14
seconds the reason that we'd like you to
do this is that this will likely happen
sometime in the next few days someone
will come up to
me and say I think my score on
checkpoint on leg 1 is wrong and I will
say okay we're gonna we have ways to
investigate that we have that you got
there at a certain time what time do you
think that you got there if your answer
is I don't know it will be more
difficult for us to investigate your
inquiry than if you say will you mark me
at 9 9 o'clock and 12 minutes and 17
seconds and I think I got there at 9
o'clock and 13 minutes if you if you
have written down what time you think
you got there that will help not
necessary if you have other things going
on they're more important but if you
could if you could write down the time
that would be helpful okay now once we
do have these times how does the scoring
work we have already calculated how long
it is good it should take you to get to
each checkpoint and to the first
checkpoint and to get from the first
checkpoint to the second checkpoint and
so on now the question is how many
checkpoints will we have each day how
many timing checkpoints how many green
signs the answer to that is anywhere
from 1 to lots and lots we do have four
or five checkpoint crews so there will
probably be at least four maybe five
maybe more timing checkpoints each day
another let's go back to the red sign
another time you will see the red sign
is at lunch most days we will stop have
you stopped at a red sign up lunch and
we will collect time allowances the
person who will do that is K and K is
this person
green shirt gray hat and she will be
asking for your time allowances at lunch
each day I've never done with a sign
Jimmy take them away and put them in the
car for further use today this is a this
is a great tool
those of you who did not wish her a
happy birthday yesterday we don't have
time for all that
any too late that was yesterday anyway
those who do not wish her a penalty let
me know didn't I wish her happy birthday
at her yesterday get a penalty today
okay continuing how does this deal work
okay let's say that and we're gonna put
the pressure here on the rookies we're
gonna see how their scores would work
first thing you have to do is know when
your start time today is the start time
of the event is 11:30 you know that from
a number of things the order of start
which you received yesterday says stage
start time for the for the hydrati
trophy run is 11:30
it also says 11:30 and instruction 1 in
the digital clock and it also says that
the start time today is 11:30 in the
event schedule then supplement - does
that mean that 117 cars pull out of the
parking lot side by side this morning at
11:30 obviously not but you do need to
know what your start time ends we're
gonna put these folks in the front row
here on the on the on the hot seat here
since they chose to sit in front bill
Franks and car 129 do you know what your
start position is and what is your start
position they well they think that their
start position is 112 if you if the rest
of you look at your orders start on the
second page near the bottom you should
see start position 112 and you should
see car 129 there you should all know
what your own start position is from
that list so what is their start
position what does their start time well
the events start time is 11:30 these
pens are not as wide as I want I hope
you can can read them
the events start time is 11:30 their
start time is a hundred and twelve
minutes later that is one hour and 52
minutes later so their start time is not
until 122 this afternoon if your start
position is 3
it's 11:30 3 if your start position is
55 its 1225 you had your start position
in minutes to the stage start time so
their official start time from the start
is 122 now let's say we have determined
that the first leg first green sign
which is now gone it should take you it
should take you and them and everyone
let's say we calculate that it should
take 42 minutes and 10 seconds to get
the check point 1 therefore we already
know the car number 129 is that your
number the car 129 should be there at
204 and 10 seconds we know that right
now that they should be there then let's
say that when they get there it's 2 O 4
and 6 seconds ok they're pretty close
they are 4 seconds early they were due
there at 204 10 they got there 204 6
they are 4 seconds early
and that is their score for leg one they
have a four second score pretty good
score they got to checkpoint one at two
don't remember what I said but let's say
I said two oh four oh six having been
four seconds early on leg one okay we
already know that the true time for leg
two is and again these are examples
these are not the correct numbers let's
say it's a short leg let's say the true
time is three minutes and nine seconds
therefore they should arrive there at
2:07 and fifteen seconds let's say they
arrive there at 207 and 20 seconds this
time they are late they are five seconds
late okay checkpoint one four seconds
early checkpoint two five seconds late
so I was like maybe those cancel out and
their score so far total for two legs is
one second what I just said is not
correct early and late arrival do not
cancel do not compensate their
cumulative so their score after two legs
would not be nine second would not be
one second would be nine seconds at the
end of the day let's say we had four
check up check points add up the four
scores for their four checkpoints
multiply it by their age factor based on
the age of their vehicle which in your
case is a 63 so they have an age factor
of 0.9 to seven or something like that
we'd multiply that and that would be
their score of the day we drank that
with the other scores of the day if they
had the best score of the day they'd be
the daily winner red badges may lead me
to believe that they're rookies if they
had the best score of the rookie class
they'd be the rookie winner no money for
today's run but there are trophies going
to be presented at the party tonight
other days there are daily trophies and
prize money for daily winners today is a
trophy run it is optional but it is a
tiebreaker down the road so if there are
two teams
when we get to California that are tied
the tiebreaker will be the team that had
the higher higher finishing position on
today's trophy run so although it
doesn't count directly toward the
championship starting tomorrow it does
although it doesn't count directly
toward the championship there is an
incentive because it does count as a
tiebreaker okay let's say that yes sir
cars should be intervals if everything
goes erratically correct no no the
thirty second thing that I mentioned is
only when you leave here tomorrow to get
to the start the 30-second interval that
I always talked about earlier has
nothing to do with today's trophy run it
has only to do with between here and the
train station tomorrow and then once
once you leave the train station it's
back to one-minute intervals so the only
30 set only 30 seconds is when it is not
not during the competition section okay
now let's have let's talk about let's
talk about what I just did because
there's a subtlety here notice that the
three minutes nine seconds true
theoretical time for this team was based
on not when they should have arrived at
checkpoint one but when they actually
did arrive at checkpoint one and that's
important and let me give you an extreme
example of that let's say instead of a
three-minute leg the second leg was an
hour
ten minutes into the legs they had a
flat tire now I'm sure they've done
their flat tire drill and let's say they
can get their flat tire changed in eight
minutes and while they're changing the
flat tire in the rain the next eight
cars go by them and they say oh my
goodness were eight minutes late this is
terrible well let's go let's see if we
can make it up and if they can make it
up before they get to the next
checkpoint then then they're good to go
so they they could they get going they
get going faster they go faster than
speed to try to make it up of course as
they are going faster than speed trying
to make it up they stay within the speed
limit they get to the first car that
they need that that pass them and pass
them okay now we're only seven minutes
late
they get to the next one now we're only
six minutes late maybe we're gonna make
it and then there's a checkpoint they
say oh my goodness we're six minutes
late that's terrible well now maybe it's
terrible but it's not as quite as bad as
they think in that we have a maximum of
late penalty at any checkpoint if you're
less than a half an hour late if only
two minutes so all they were although
they were six minutes late they only
have a two-minute penalty so far here's
where they can group go wrong if they
say okay let's make up those other six
minutes and they pass six more cars and
now they're a minute behind the blue car
and they started behind the blue car
when they started the day we're back in
sync what they have done just done now
is exactly wrong each leg starts from
scratch when you get to the checkpoint
when you get to the green sign which
means that on the second leg they will
be six minutes early having been two
minutes late at the second leg now we're
not quite so forgiving on early arrival
if you're if you're early at a
checkpoint you get up to a five minute
penalty so if they did what I said and
tried to make up on the subsequent leg
they now have a two minute late for the
flat tire five minutes early because
they didn't understand how things worked
seven minutes they probably won't be at
the top of the leaderboard at the end of
the day the point here is once you get
to that checkpoint you are now dead on
time for the next leg if you if you at
that point get go back to speeds follow
the instructions even though you're six
minutes behind where you shoot where you
think you should be you can still get a
perfect score we call that an ace on the
next leg and have good scores for the
rest of the day if you do get an ace a
perfect score on a leg we give you some
ace stickers and you may have seen some
cars that have lots of stickers on them
on them any questions about the timing
how the competition works this is a
fairly informal thing if you have a
question raise your hand I'll try to get
to you I may finish my thought before I
recognize you but raise your hand and
we'll if I said something wrong
something you didn't understand
something that I missed okay let's talk
about the course and
structions you've already received your
course instructions now this is very
important most mornings you will receive
your course instructions from Steve
who's waving in the back of the room
green shirt everyone turn around
say hi to Steve Steve and Vicky will
give you your course instructions most
mornings for stages two through the end
through through nine you get course
instructions from him a half an hour
before your start time your course
instructions for tomorrow you get at the
finish line under the front canopy when
you get to the finish today so make sure
we give those to you and again remember
your orders start for tomorrow we don't
give you a separate one tonight when you
get in because it's the same piece of
paper you already have how do you follow
the course instructions well to start
with each course instruction has five
columns the first column does not have a
letter at the top look at page one of
your course instructions it has numbers
and they're in order one two three four
five you must do everything that
instruction one requires then go on to
instruction to everything that
instruction two requires then go on to
instruction three column a has what we
call cameo diagrams of intersection and
sign configurations column B tells you
the portion of the event that is
beginning at that place column C gives
timing and speed information and column
D is our hint column it tells you in
conjunction with column a it helps you
do the instruction correctly we're going
to talk about columns a and D to start
with column a shows a right turn you're
leaving the holiday in the holiday n
will be behind you that is this building
you are making a right turn onto
something called Watson Road the words
rocks and rotor in parentheses because
the road name may not be identified as
you make the turn but you either know
it's Watson Road because you've been
there for three days or at the next
intersection it will be identified just
to make sure you're turning out of the
front side of the hotel to leave today
on to Watson Road do not turn out of the
side by the whatever to Steak and Shake
on to Lindbergh or Kirkwood Road and
we're also telling you in column D that
you may encounter support vehicles in
Kirkwood today without them getting a
penalty next time so the instruction has
a bull a dot at the bottom that shows
your position as you enter the
intersection an arrow to the right that
shows your position as you leave the
intersection a bold line from the dot to
the arrow that represents your route
through the intersection and a thin line
to the left the thin line represents to
paraphrase Robert Frost the road or
roads not taken checkpoint two shows you
going straight at a traffic light new
symbol the name of the road to the right
at the traffic light is Guyer Road and
we're giving you a hint and trick column
D that it's the second traffic light
you'll come to if we haven't told you it
was the second traffic light you'd come
to you'd have to get to the first
traffic light sees that is this guy no
it's not at sunset office get to the
second traffic light is this guy or yes
it is this is the instruction in this
case we're helping you by telling you
it'll be the second traffic light you
come to instruction three is different
not an intersection it's a sign it's an
overhead sign it's you can tell it's an
overhead sign because the sign the arrow
represents your position the sign is
sort of on top of the arrow overhead
sign I'm giving you a hint column D that
it comes quick comes quick after
instruction two it has the word Chicago
Memphis will that be all the words on
the sign not necessarily in this case I
think it says interstate 270 East West
or some other stuff but Chicago Memphis
will be among the wording on the sign
and will be a prominent portion of the
wording Nexen such instruction number
four is sort of a triple or a double
intersection a road will be going off to
the last thin road road not taken don't
take it go straight a road will be going
off to the right again thin road don't
take it you will stay on the middle road
go towards south I 270 tour
Memphis and again that one comes quick
the next instruction is a sign on the
right arrow represents your position
arrow is on the left sign is on the
right the sign will be on the right I'm
giving you a hand because most free
you'll be on the freeway most freeway
signs are green that'll be a brown sign
just to have make sure you get the right
sign yes yes I'm going to talk about B
and C later if that's the question
cullum sick six sign on the right saying
Hospital instructions seven overhead
signs saying interstate 255 Chicago and
we need you to merge last column D to
take that road don't take an exit to
take interstate something else merge
left to stay on interstate 255 I - is
our abbreviation for interstate
Mississippi River sign on instruction
nine Illinois state line and instruction
ten struction eleven has information in
brackets in column D bracketed
information is interesting stuff that
you can completely ignore but given that
we're doing a lot of highway 66 stuff
and a lot of a lot of historic stuff I
will be giving you historic comments in
brackets occasionally in column D
instructions fourteen overhead sign
instruction 15a Brown sign instruction
18 again a double intersection you'll
exit to the right and then you'll exit
to the right again to take exit 30
toward Indianapolis instruction 20
you'll take highway 159 at exit 12
instruction 21 you'll turn left at the
traffic light at the end of the off-ramp
I'm giving you 45 minutes for lunch
today
if you leave here a little early and
this may go against what you think I've
told you already but you can leave
earlier than your official start time
here without penalty these folks can
leave earlier than their official start
time of 152 without penalty I'll tell
you in a moment when you have
we'll be on time but don't leave too
early or you'll just be sitting out in
the rain
for a long time if you want to leave a
few minutes early I'm giving you 45
minutes for lunch number of restaurants
where you can choose to have lunch if
you leave here 15 minutes early you'll
have an hour for lunch instruction 22
shows you're going straight to crossed
Schwartz street there is a
jack-in-the-box on the font on the near
right corner that's not the first
jack-in-the-box you'll come to is if you
look up at instruction 21 you'll see
there's a different jack-in-the-box
among the restaurants and instruction 21
instruction 24 there's a dashed road
what does that mean the rules say that
you will not take private roads dead-end
roads
unpaved roads questionable roads unless
there's an instruction they will also
tell you that you that such roads may be
identified by a dashed line instruction
24 the road with a daft will be one of
those it might be an alley it might be a
might be a dead-end road instruction 25
is a speed limit 40 instruction 26 is
the next speed limit 40 instruction 27
is a curve warning sign double sign
curve on top 35 miles per hour
underneath instruction 28 is not a speed
limit 45 sign it is a speed limit 45
ahead sign diamond-shaped sign
yellow background typically arrow saying
speed limit becomes 45 up there
someplace okay here's a general question
for people which direction do we go when
we get to instruction 30 someone said
left I have an instruction here that
says instruction 30 says we go straight
ahead why did people say left make sure
you have the emergency instructions make
sure you do the emergency instructions
the road is closed and add instruction
30 so make sure that you have the
urgency instructions and do what they
say between instruction 29 and 31 we are
directing you on a detour instruction 32
is a stop ahead sign not the stop sign
itself a yellow sign saying there's a
stop sign ahead instruction 33 you will
go right at a stop sign that's sort of a
slanty intersection instruction 34 you
will go straight at a stop sign comes
quickly after the previous instruction
instruction 37 a right turn on Church
Street interesting information perhaps
in column D instruction 38 comes quick
instruction 40 you're turning on to a
divided highway the road ahead will be
unpaved or dead-end or something at a
stop sign again between instruction 40
and 41
there's your emergency instructions will
tell you to follow in deep a marked
detour instructions 45 follow this curve
warning sign and column D what does that
mean well let's go back to instruction
to where it says second traffic light
nobody asks the question wait a minute
you're telling me what to do with the
second traffic light why didn't you tell
me what to do at the first traffic light
and a further part of that question is
you're showing us what to do at some
intersections what do we do with the
intersections that you don't show us and
the reason that you didn't ask the
reason I didn't address it is the answer
should be fairly obvious and the answer
is keep on going so obviously at
instruction 2 when you get to the first
traffic light you just go straight and
eventually you get to the second traffic
light now the what I'm addressing is is
exactly what I said what do you do when
there's no instruction the event
regulations specify that and they say
follow the obvious principal Road in
most cases the obvious principal
is the road directly ahead but in the
instruction in question instruction 45
the situation will be something like
this here is the sine curve warning sign
with 25 miles per hour and out of it the
road configuration will be something
like this the center stripe will take
you this way
there might be a stop sign on this road
ahead saying that this is a lesser Road
if your grandmother said come visit me
get on this road and keep on going you
would go around that corner without
giving it another thought you would
consider that the obvious principal Road
if I hadn't given you an instruction and
you didn't give it at any thought you
would go that way if you gave it too
much thought you might say oh which way
do I go anyway I am hopefully laying
that dilemma by telling you follow this
curve warning sign and follow the
obvious principal road and go the way
that the current warning sign directs
you cookies at this point are a little
bit uneasy saying but I'm afraid that
sometimes I'm going to get confused and
I won't be able to figure that out and
my answer to that is I think I have
tried very hard that your your concern
will not will not occur
continuing instruction 49 sort of a
different instruction it's sort of two
components there is a sign and an
intersection you turn right on the
slanty crossroad but only after you pass
the sign the crossroad side you come to
a crossroad sign diamond-shaped yellow
sign with a plus on it and then turn
right 55 I give you a hint that the
Kansas Street sign is a street naming
sign like a city little small city sign
and this is the first one of these this
is a sign on the left all the signs so
far have been over here
or on the right this ones on the left
arrow shows your position sign on the
left of the arrow sign on the left of
the road question yes fraction 49 yes
talk about that when we do talk about
column C but at the side I will address
the question she asked in general in a
moment or bill Kroger will struction 57
I'm giving you a double hint one when
you turn on possum Hill Road it's the
first paved road you come to and second
the sign identifying possum Hill Road
will be on the left by the time you get
to 61 you're done with the competition
for the day and instruction 62 I'm sure
you'll be ready for a break and we need
you to fill up some gas because the next
refueling stop isn't for 190 miles we
think you all have 200 mile range so if
you refuel there you should have enough
gas to get to the next row fueling stop
struction 63 go under a bridge left
under a traffic light on to 255 South
instructions 64 a sign on the right 65
sign overhead 66 double interchange
thing head toward Kansas City next page
lots of overhead signs instructions 76
left turned into the Holiday Inn that's
from Watson Road checkered flag done for
the day comes very quick after the
previous instruction stop at the
observation checkpoint stop at the red
sign under the canopy we're gonna be
checking you in we're gonna be talking
we're going to be talking to each team
for hopefully a minute otherwise you'll
get backed up I anticipate that some of
you will be getting backed up just sit
there in the rain until you can pull up
and talk to us there hopefully the rain
will have stopped by then more
information are the two finished boxes
the two oval boxes with rounded corners
on pages 11 and 12 or 3 these are what
we call finish boxes they give you
information about this evening's
activities the first one tells you about
the reminder of the social
and we're giving out trophies for
today's run tonight we also tell you
about race car parking for tonight
the next box gives you information about
the next day's run we give you the
city's Kirkwood - Springfield will tell
it we tell you when and where and how to
receive your course instructions again
it'll be at the finish line today we
give you the breakfast start times at
each hotel for the next morning again we
tell you how to reach the start and
again this is the only time you'll be at
30-second intervals we remind you of the
start time of the next day's run and we
also tell you how far it'll be to the
first refueling stop of the next day's
run normally we don't go 2 days ahead as
I've done here but collect those
quarters any questions on columns a or B
I'm sorry a or D yes sir instructions 64
oh the sign sounds interstate 270 and
then there's a big space and then
there's a sex it means interstate 270 is
6 miles ahead and again there may be
other things on the sign it may say flu
/ Ville 3 interstate 276 Memphis 109
Pflugerville maybe 4 I don't know
okay we're talking about columns B and C
after we answer your question
the next refuelling stop is 190 miles
from this point including the rest of
today's run including the five miles to
the start tomorrow morning and then down
the road tomorrow the next refuel
now you will have other opportunities to
refuel if you have 250 mile range we
encourage you to refuel when we tell you
to if you refuse you have 200 mile range
and refuel when we tell you to you'll
work out fine we expect you to start
today with a fairly full tank of fuel
but if you don't although it's not
listed during the lunch break where
there are all those restaurants listed
there also a number of gas stations
there so you can get refuel there even
though we don't tell you to okay columns
B and C struction one begin the tire
warm-up to mile two and a half mile tire
warm-up take five minutes giving you the
time zone central Daylight Time 11:30
again your start time is 11:30 plus your
start position you can leave earlier
than that we encourage you to we're a
little late on rally school so the early
cars may not have a lot of time after
the end of rally school but if your time
is approaching and Raleigh still still
going on you might want to leave but I
think mostly rookies will be at the
second part of rally school and I think
the first few cars in the order of
starter are not rookies so that'll so
that'll give you that give you extra
time here anyway you can leave here
early without penalty tire warmup is two
and a half miles let you bring your
tires up to normal operating temperature
how far does that go that goes to the
next thing in column Fah in column B
which is instruction five so two and a
half miles approximately from
instruction one to instruction five and
we're giving you five minutes to travel
those two and a half miles now you're
thinking we'll wait a minute two and a
half miles that's interesting but what
do I care
those those darn guys over vehicle
inspection made sure I didn't have an
odometer and that's correct you can't
measure that two and a half miles but
it's just to give you an idea of how far
portion is if your our two into the
event and you think you're still on the
tire warm-up you've probably done
something wrong
instruction five we begin the
speedometer calibration run it's thirty
four miles long we're giving you forty
two minutes to do it we're allowing you
to calibrate your your speedometer at a
speed of fifty as you pass the ulysses s
grant sign on the right again it's a
brown sign start your stopwatch write
down the time on your time of day watch
or both when you get to the hospital
sign if L ends and be going fifty be
going at that point what you think is
fifty at the hospital sign it should
take you you should be there in two
minutes thirty five and a half seconds
when you get to the overhead Chicago
sign it should be five minutes three
point eight seconds all the way back
from the ulysses grant sign there two
numbers shown right hand numbers from
the beginning of the calibration last
hand number is the interval time from
the previous instruction we recommend
that you we recommend that you do only
that you pay attention to the cumulative
times right hand not the not the
interval times that they're there if you
want them yes
that's approximate yes what is the two
minutes mean good question I skipped
that over and I should have done that
instruction for has two minutes in
parentheses what does that mean does
that mean you have an extra two minutes
added to the five minutes no the
parenthetical time is how far it should
take you how long it should take you to
get to the end of this thing when you
get to instruction 4 you are
approximately two minutes from the
ulysses s grant sign parenthetical times
how far you are to the end of the
transit that you're in anyway check your
calibration signs all the way up to
instruction 17 at instruction 17 if your
time is 41 minutes 2.6 seconds good for
you
I can assure you it won't be you will
need to make an adjustment based on that
and I get off easy because I'm not going
to tell you how to do that but he is
after the break
yes yes we do have the Oh on the on the
tire warm-up you could drive any safe
speed on the calibration run we do give
you a speed and that speed is 50 now
that instruction 17 again we don't give
you a speed instruction 17 we give you
11 mile transept that's your lunch break
we give you 58 minutes that's 58 minutes
both 45 minutes approximately for lunch
and some time to drive the 11 miles
again drive at any safe speed we often
put you in transits to get you through
congested areas traffic lights and so on
when you get to instruction 21 you are
10 minutes approximately from when the
competition really begins at instruction
28 26 thank you yes when you get to the
second jack-in-the-box of instruction 22
it's still three minutes down the road
when you get to the turn on the vandalia
it's two minutes down the road when you
get to the first speed limit 40 the
beginning of the competition which is at
the next speed limit 40 not the first
one is about 15 seconds beyond that
finally at instruction 26 the
competition really begins that's the
point you need to leave on time now
don't pull up to that sign the speed
limit 40 sign the second speed limit 40
sign don't pull up to that sign until
it's your minute because the car that's
a minute ahead of you will want to pull
up and leave there exactly on his minute
after he goes and you know who he is
because you've got your order to start
then it's time for you to pull up our
folks here in position 112 hopefully an
instruction 26 have already calculated
what their restart time is and all of
you perhaps should have and have written
down that the restart time is a hundred
and twelve minutes which is an hour and
52 minutes later than that
so their restart time at this point and
they should have already written it down
and if they haven't they're about to
we'll be if I've done the arithmetic
correctly at 307 when they leave they're
at 307 they are now for the first time
on the clock there could now be a green
sign which is now gone
at any point be starting them there is
never a green sign until after the
second digital clock of the day and I'm
also telling you that there's limited
parking so stay if your rest stay at the
restaurants until it gets close to your
departure time well there'll be lots of
cars parked along the side of the road
and in the rain and limited parking
it'll be sort of a mess yes well you you
leave it your you leave it your time
your correct maybe yeah maybe the person
who ahead of you it doesn't like rain
and isn't running today but yes leave at
your time but if you see the car ahead
of it
you know don't but wait till you're a
minute to pull up because maybe he's
gonna pull up at the last second yes sir
we try to we try to do the entrance in
safe locations this one is a state
highway I believe but it is a fairly
untraveled state highway it is in fact
as it says that instruction 22 its
historic 66 and the interstate is a mile
over and parallel so most of the traffic
is on the interstate
okay instruction 27 yes sir are some
cars do it differently we don't
recommend it some cars do not stop at
the sign some star cars come up from
behind on zat's P I don't want to think
about it if some cars do it differently
you don't talk about running starts I
hope good instruction 27 this is your
first speed change this is a delayed
speed change when you get to the sign
continue at 36 seconds continue at the
previous speed oh my god I don't know
what the previous speed is it's not on
this page no it's not continue at 35
miles per hour you have to turn to the
previous page to figure out what it was
and your speed change is 36 seconds
later at instruction 28 you do your
speed change to 40 as you quiet please
instruction 48:28 speed change to 40 at
the sign instruction 29 speed change at
the sign bill will tell you how to do
the speed change maneuver instruction 29
is not a speed change that's corrected
instruction 29 has been superseded by an
emergency situation instruction 33 is a
pause your first pause of the day your
first positive the day would have been
instruction 30 but a pause is a time
with zero miles an hour ahead of it it
means you stopped for a length of time
so as to delay 15 seconds does that mean
you come to a full stop for 15 seconds
and then go probably not
bill quiet please bill croaker will
address the speed change maneuver after
the break
another pause at instruction 24 speed
change I'm sorry 34 speed change on 35
pause on 36 struction 38 is a triple
speed change speed change at the sign 36
seconds then you speed up from 35 to 40
then you go for 4 minutes and 12 seconds
on your stopwatch your time if they
watch and then slow to 30 struction 39
we begin a transit that's your morning
break several places where you can find
restrooms maybe even gas if you need it
three and a half miles approximately
from instruction 39 to 45 the paired
symbols you hold on hold on a second let
me get through this and then we'll take
your questions three and a half miles
approximately from the hourglass with
the sand at the top to the hourglass
with the sand at the bottom we're giving
you exactly 25 minutes to do that that
instruction 35:39 quiet please that
instruction 39 we will start you should
start your stopwatch and instruction 45
you leave there exactly 25 minutes after
the time you got to instruction 39 if
you do not know when you got to
instruction 39 you will not know when to
leave instruction 45 and will not get a
good score during those 25 minutes we're
giving you 15 minutes typically for a
break that's what the symbol and column
B means that's our euphemistically
euphemistically called rest stop symbol
there's a Dairy Queen of KC's a Phillips
and the Z acts gas at which you might
take a break question yes
yes same thing happens between 29 and 31
based on the emergency instructions and
instruction 29 write down your time as
six minutes and that's when you leave
instruction 31 you don't see that in the
course instructions that is all covered
by the emergency instructions going back
you should be going 30 when you leave
instruction 26 you're going a speed of
35 you continue at 35 so you get to
instruction 27 no no no it could be
miles down the road when you finally get
to instruction 27 you keep going 35 for
another 36 seconds at the sign of 30 at
27 the distance between these signs you
won't know in advance when you go left
at instruction 43 you will be following
the center stripe that instruction 45
we've talked about that
follow the curve warning sign
instruction 49 is a double instruction
cross road sign make a right turn on an
instruction like this you do your speed
change not at the intersection but at
the crossroad sign instruction 53 stop
sign go straight speed 15 instruction 55
is a sign on the left
57 speed change it appears that every
instruction through here and I was
hoping there was one without didn't has
a speed change let's say that
instruction 51 warden 1100 didn't have a
speed change let's say the column C was
blank would that mean you can go any
speed you want obviously not if there's
no speed given it just means no speed
change no change keep going the previous
speed so if instruction 51 did not have
a 20 miles per hour in column C you
would continue at the previous speed
which is in this case 25 finally when
you get to instruction 61 and time
portion that's the digital clock with
the slash across it end time portion for
the day you're not done for the day you
still have 54 miles to get to the finish
we're giving you an hour and 25 minutes
to get
their question but back to the emergency
instructions you have exactly six
minutes to get in from instruction
twenty nine to instruction thirty one so
make sure you write down your time at
instruction twenty nine so you know when
to leave instruction thirty one and then
you continue on with thirty one you
leave the speed limit 55 just like you
did before at a speed of 45 well no I
mean you wait there just like you did at
the other end transit wait for the car
ahead of you to believe when your time
comes time to go okay yes sir
talking about instruction 61 yes I
that's where I was headed
instruction 61 you're done with
competition for the day
no more green checkpoint signs drive at
a safe speed to the finish we're giving
you 15 minutes for fuel we're also
giving you time to drive down the
freeway
it may take you more than an hour 25 on
the freeway afternoon rush hour in the
rain we don't know we'll take that into
account typically you have an extra 30
minutes from the time we get here before
we give you a penalty for being late at
the final observation checkpoint the red
sign at the finish today because of the
rain and freeway traffic we may extend
that but we need you to we need you to
take 15 minutes up to 15 minutes to get
gas and then come on in as quickly as
possible right if you're too late you'll
get a did not finish for the day and you
will have missed the reception and the
trophies that and the trophy that you
didn't win okay those instructions from
61 to the finish will get you to the
finish again at instruction 76 we end
you're done for the day checkered flag
make sure you stop at the observation
checkpoint if you pull into the parking
lot at the at the Holiday Inn go around
back park your car and don't check in at
the observation checkpoint you will get
a score of did not finish for among
other reasons that we don't know that
you finish that's why you have to check
in at the finish okay I'm gonna take a
couple of questions then we're gonna
take a quick break and I was supposed to
be done by my portion by tan and we got
a little late start so we're pretty good
hold on don't we got a couple questions
there are restrooms well you found the
restrooms we'll reconvene at 10:20
question
correct correct
if it's beyond the hour and 55 minutes
you go to DNF well if you it gets
changed to a finished no score if you if
you make it under your own power it gets
changed or finished no score but for all
purposes it's the same thing yes
thirty minutes and flexible depending on
we may extend it on traffic most days we
will not extend it okay we'll see you
back hold on Steve hold on
if you are not running today if you've
decided not to run for whatever reason
tell Steve and Vicky so we aren't
looking for you